what can you tell us well she was at a
conference attended by quite a lot of
businessmen and she sent a Twitter which
basically mocks or seemed to mock the
way that some people who don't speak
English as their first language mix up
their arse and their else if we take a
look at their first tweet it's over the
face basically says did they only come
for the lice and petroleum all right now
see that's it's not in your Spanish your
best Spanish what is that is better no
no that's not it's so funny is it really
particularly what kind of worthy of a
full of eight-year-old really she wrote
it in Spanish and apparently it was in
yeah in response to some comments and
criticism that had been made that her
events always packed with her supporters
that's not unusual I don't think for for
a leader of a country exactly the best
week for either is it given that we've
also had that this mysterious death of
well yes that's right so social storm is
my actual she's now saying it wasn't a
suicide it's a conspiracy she was
raising it but they just found a warrant
to 28-page don't warrant for her arrest
also been committing on this on Twitter
as well she's important to end a
presidency is in it no she's got a few
more months left she might be able to
make a few more comments at me we do
think somebody was accommodated because
some commented was in that she's had the
reverse learning curve of any media
member here was right let's get to a
China because they haven't had much have
their here no so far we haven't as far
as I know had any reaction from China
China of course is a really important
trading partner for Argentina actually
the second biggest for Argentina after
Brazil and it did something like 17
point five billion dollars worth of
Commerce in 2013 so very important for
Argentina so far we haven't had in
reaction from them actually you know she
is still in China she continues her trip
today and she'll also meet so he kachunk
she met President Xi Jinping yesterday
she signed quite a few deals and there
was a comment there from the executive
director at the Argentine China Chamber
of Commerce in Buenos Aires who said I
don't believe the Chinese are reading
our president tweets all day yes what
somebody is somebody's reading them yeah
I'm taking you all there you taking him
up to his office and go here you go sir
have a look at this
Twitter Jake we got banned in China but
yes there are ways and means i'm not
sure the authorities want to know what
China could actually have said to that
know how do you know what you got to
also look at it from a degree of
hypocrisy okay I mean this is a racist
slur but don't forget when John Locke
who was a yes to Gary la tarea John
Locke was of course the philosopher Gary
Locke was leaving China the Xinhua the
state media took caught him a rotten
banana I mean that's not exactly
particularly nice is it no name-calling
wish rule friends here that's right not
much she's still in China and she leave
soon I message and so far genlock the
boat so it's too much as far as we can
see on the terminal rock the boat well
what is getting way to end the visitor